[Music] Just
think, all the shopkeepers who
fire Muslim employees from their shops,
if they don't fire them,
declare them traitors of the Com, then those shopkeepers who are comrades should
listen carefully and if
any Pahadi Muslim works in their shop, they will
immediately fire them.  Remove him from your shops, then within
two days time, if after that any
shopkeeper keeps a Muslim in his shop,
we will reduce the posting of boycotting him outside his shop and that
[music]
is an incident in our house, you one thing.  Keep in mind
how many districts are there inside Haryana
[Music]
Muslims will
rise, no one will be left [
Music] [
Music]
[Music]